on dit souvent qu'en politique il faut
savoir faire et faire savoir agir et
communiquer c'est le Light motif de mon
invité qui compte incarner la relève de
la droite à l'Assemblée
[Musique]
bonjour Antoine ver Morel bonjour alors
à l'adolescent à 14 ans quand la plupart
des ados cherche à faire pression sur
leurs parents pour pouvoir sortir le
samedi soir vous vous avez fait pression
sur votre père pour pouvoir aller à un
meeting de Nicolas Sarkozy à
Clermont-Ferrand c'est ça exactement et
c'était le premier King de ma vie c'est
un meeting sur la ruralité
on est en 2007 c'était la pleine folie
Sarkozy c'était on croyait en l'homme
mon père qui n'était jamais l'air
meeting électoral qui n'a jamais été
encarté je peux pas conduire donc il
faut que tu m'emmènes je vais y aller
etc et alors au même âge vous avez aussi
fait votre stage de 3e chez le député de
votre circonscription
j'ai fait un stage d'une semaine avec
lui c'était mon stage de 3e qui était
député de ma circonscription de 1993 à
2017 ça donne juste l'impression que
vous avez toujours su que vous feriez de
la politique j'avais ça en moi je sais
pas d'où ça vient j'ai quelques idées
mais effectivement dans ma famille on
n'a jamais fait de politique on n'a
jamais été encarté ou élu et pour autant
depuis tout petit mon premier souvenir
politique ça reste 2002 j'avais 9 ans et
j'ai 16 ans Marie Le Pen aux acteurs de
la présidentielle alors le problème si
on peut dire c'est que on peut pas se
présenter une élection avant d'avoir 18
ans du coup vous êtes tourné vers
l'engagement associatif et vous avez
fondé présidé plein d'associations vous
avez notamment créé un réseau social
d'entrée de territoriale qui s'appelle
l'annuaire rouennais vous avez mis aussi
en place un réseau d'aide aux devoirs
pour des jeunes demandeurs d'asile à
Dijon et puis vous avez assigné Bouygues
Telecom pour publicité mensongère sur
son taux de couverture 4G dans votre
département pour améliorer la couverture
du réseau de téléphonie mobile qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui a alimenté cette
frénésie d'action aussi jeune chez vous
c'était quoi votre moteur je suis fils
d'éleveur laitier j'ai toujours habité à
la campagne j'ai aussi vu ces injustices
territoriales qui arrivaient et qui sont
aujourd'hui flagrantes dans notre pays
et j'ai voulu à mon échelle m'engager
j'ai été délégué de classe des
engagements qui étaient très modestes
très humbles des professeurs qui m'ont
aussi tendu la main qui à un moment
donné m'ont montré cette voix de
l'engagement associatif et qui ont fait
que je me suis dit bah on peut essayer
de changer les choses à notre échelle
par les associations et donc c'est pour
ça que je me suis engagé dans
différentes et puis ensuite j'en ai créé
aussi quelques-unes qui sont d'ailleurs
toujours d'actualité aujourd'hui et
alors votre principale fait d'arme si
l'on peut dire dans le domaine
associatif c'est la création d'un
collectif touche pas à ma bourse je la
mérite collectif contre la suppression
de la bourse au mérite en 2014 et ça
vous a valu de faire votre première
télévision
Antoine Vermorel a désormais un peu de
mal à joindre les deux bouts je suis
fils d'Ever laitier je viens d'un milieu
plutôt modeste j'avais eu mon baccalauré
avec 18,3 de moyenne et donc j'avais une
bourse de 1800 euros par an environ 200
euros par mois pendant mon année
universitaire depuis cet été la
mobilisation a grossi courrier au
députés français pétition sur internet
intitulée touche pas à ma bourse je la
mérite enfin sur le plan européen
Antoine et ses amis souhaitent créer une
bourse européenne et d'opéra ainsi la
mobilité alors cette bataille contre la
ministre de l'Éducation de l'époque vous
l'avez gagné vous avez obtenu
l'annulation de la circulaire en allant
devant le Conseil d'État
cette victoire elle a changé beaucoup de
choses dans votre vie c'est c'était un
moment fondateur à la fois de mon
engagement politique ces moments où je
passe de l'associatif aux politiques
c'est aussi le moment où je me rends
compte que l'engagement peut avoir de
vrais résultats puisque si avec
mes collègues étudiants n'avaient pas
attaqué cette décision au Conseil d'État
la bourse on mérite aujourd'hui elle
n'existerait pas et elle a été rétablie
grâce à cette décision et ça m'a permis
aussi d'assumer pleinement qui j'étais
d'où je venais pourquoi j'étais engagé
en politique et ce que certains avaient
pu me faire voir notamment dans mes
études supérieures à Sciences Po comme
une sorte de difficulté sociale le fait
que je vienne d'un milieu ou très peu
ensuite font des études supérieures et
ben c'était le moment de dire bah oui je
suis fils d'élever laitier et j'en suis
très fier et je reste très fier de mes
racines agricoles comme j'ai toujours
été et malgré ce ce mépris social qu'on
peut avoir parfois d'en faire une force
plutôt que un handicap vous avez jamais
envisagé de reprendre la ferme de votre
père je crois non je pour autant
j'aidais enfin j'ai toujours ce souvenir
là de de quelques enfin c'était à la
maison c'était les devoirs d'abord et
une fois que les devoirs étaient finis
avec maman mon père m'emmenait à
l'extérieur et puis j'avais jamais
l'aider à la faire mais vous savez c'est
un métier qui est difficile c'est la
traite c'est le matin et le soir je me
souviens que les repas de famille le
dimanche midi on devait rentrer plutôt
parce que mon père avait la traite et
puis aussi cette crise de 2009 la crise
laitière ou malgré tout le travail que
vous fournissez vous n'avez pas de
revenus suffisants pour faire vivre
votre votre famille et donc c'est pour
ça que différentes raisons ont fait que
mais je suis très content que mon père
est probablement retrouver quelqu'un là
pour la retraite pour reprendre
l'exploitation et c'est une vraie
richesse familiale mais ce milieu social
dans lequel vous avez vous avez grandi
ça nourrit votre engagement politique
aujourd'hui oui parce que je j'ai vécu
aussi cette forme de déconnexion de
certains élus ou le reproche que mes
parents peuvent faire parfois à des élus
aussi et je fais attention de ne pas
leur ressembler évidemment mais c'est
toujours un risque que de être dans les
instances parisiennes et tout ça et
d'oublier d'oulon vient et d'ailleurs la
dernière promesse de campagne je me
souviendrai toujours avec ma suppléante
Fanny fait nous c'était de dire quoi
qu'il arrive dimanche prochain on se
souviendra de d'où l'on vient et ça
c'est je pense c'est une belle promesse
aussi qu'on peut faire à tous les
électeurs qui nous font confiance au
moment d'une élection alors pour revenir
à ce combat contre la suppression de la
bourse au mérite ça va vous aussi nous a
permis de rencontrer plusieurs
responsables politiques de la droite
parlementaire
erikietty Laurent Wauquiez Michel
Barnier dont vous êtes resté assez
proche un pot politiquement ça vous a
aidé donc à vous lancer en politique oui
et ça a été effectivement la rencontre
avec Michel Barnier qui est resté
aujourd'hui un ami que j'ai accueilli
chez moi pendant le congrès des
républicains qui encore aujourd'hui
ont des jeunes on se voit régulièrement
en échange pour moi son expérience elle
est source d'enrichissement très
important quoi et ça a été effectivement
l'occasion de rencontrer aussi les élus
la droite que je suivais depuis beaucoup
plus longtemps évidemment mais à un
moment où on se dit bah tiens pourquoi
pas moi quoi et en 2017 vous devenez
collaborateur parlementaire de deux
députés LR Robin Reda et Damien Abad
Damien Abad qui est devenu quelque temps
plus tard le président du groupe les
républicains à l'Assemblée et là vous
avez pris du gallon si l'on peut dire
vous êtes devenu collaborateur de groupe
toutes ces années vous ont permis
j'imagine de d'apprendre un peu sur le
fonctionnement du Parlement sur les
parlementaires mais au-delà de cela
quelles leçons vous en avez tiré sur le
mandat de député
cette nécessité qui est à la fois dans
un pour des députés de l'opposition de
faire des propositions de faire vivre le
débat public et aussi cette importance
d'être enraciné localement Damien et
Robin sont deux députés qui maintenant
ont fait d'autres choix politiques que
moi et pour autant il reste très
enraciné dans la majorité présidentielle
aujourd'hui
cirception très proche aussi de leurs
habitants et j'ai appris ça de leur part
aussi en plus de mon engagement
personnel alors on a vu que vous avez du
patienter avant de vous lancer en
politique mais alors une fois que vous
êtes lancé tout est allé très vite vous
avez été élu adjoint au maire de votre
commune Renaison en 2020 puis
vice-président de l'agglomération de
Roanne conseiller départemental
également ça donne l'impression qu'il y
a un petit côté homme pressé chez vous
c'est ce que mes opposants disent après
ce que les habitants aussi reconnaissent
c'est mon dynamisme mon énergie la
volonté de faire bouger les choses donc
c'est pressé pressé d'agir mais on sent
j'ai envie de faire j'ai envie de faire
bouger les lignes j'ai aussi envie que
une nouvelle génération arrive et je me
félicite au département d'ailleurs il y
a des élus de l'opposition qui sont
jeunes comme moi et je sens très bien
qu'ils ont cette volonté là aussi de
faire bouger les lignes peut-être
différemment que moi mais il y a une
volonté la nouvelle génération de d'y
aller et c'est plutôt une bonne chose je
pense vu le taux d'abstention est vu
souvent le désintérêt de la jeunesse
vis-à-vis de la politique quoi alors
pendant la campagne des législatives
vous avez mis un point d'honneur à vous
rendre dans chacune des 91 communes de
votre circonscription et vous n'avez pas
manqué de le faire savoir en posant
devant les panneaux à chaque fois on
sent que la communication en politique
alors c'est pas toujours très bien vu
mais vous vous l'assumez je considère
que c'est un gage de transparence aussi
et c'est souvent ce qu'on me dit aussi
au moins vous on sait ce que vous faites
quoi après on n'est pas toujours
d'accord avec moi avec mes votes et tout
ça mais je me cache pas de ce que je
fais et de ce que je porte et je pense
que c'est important vous savez Victor
Hugo disait la forme la communication
pardon c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface et donc l'enjeu c'est pas
uniquement de communiquer pour
communiquer c'est juste de de faire et
ensuite de faire savoir et c'est ça que
je me fixe comme objectif dans mes
mandats et puis alors on a pas mal par
mail est parlé de vous au début de votre
mandat parce que vous avez décidé de
tenir vos permanences dans un
camping-car pour aller à la rencontre de
de vos concitoyens mais là aussi ça peut
faire un peu un peu gadget peut-être un
peu communication à bon prix c'est pas
gadget j'ai pas de permanence
parlementaire physique donc c'est un
choix personnel j'ai un bureau qui fait
3 mètres par 3 mètres certains de mes
collègues ont des bureaux beaucoup plus
grands et c'est un autre choix mais ma
volonté ma circonscription du Nord au
Sud d'estomac ça fait 1h30 je sais
d'ores et déjà que dans mon mandat il y
a des personnes que je ne pourrai pas
rencontrer et c'est ce choix que j'ai
fait je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs il y
a d'autres députés d'autres bords qui
l'ont fait et aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré
même des chefs d'entreprise qui me
disent ah bah tiens j'ai vu votre
permanence mobile je pensais pas venir
vous voir j'ai rien à vous demander j'ai
des choses à vous proposer et j'en
profite donc ça va te permettre de
rencontrer et de d'affirmer cet enjeu de
la proximité alors on sent pressé d'agir
précédemment des résultats à l’assemblée
en même pas 10 mois vous avez déposé 12
propositions de loi c'est c'est énorme
c'est plus que ce que la plupart des
députés présentent en 5 ans mais combien
ont été mises à l'ordre du joueur de
l'assemblée il faut se battre pour
qu'elle le soit ou qu'elle soit intégrée
ensuite dans les textes législatifs
après pour moi ils ont pas été examinés
on est d'accord non mais bon ça sert à
quoi la question la première chose c'est
que c'est un acte politique fort j'en ai
fait une par exemple sur la suppression
des allocations aux parents maltraitants
qui m'a valu un rendez-vous avec la
secrétaire d'État en charge de l'enfance
qui m'a dit on étudie cette proposition
pour l'intégrer dans le projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale à
l'automne donc elle est proposition de
loi qui peuvent être transformées en
communication au service de l'action et
c'est aussi j'en ai déposé une récemment
sur la nationale 7 à Mably qui est un
sujet local qui m'intéresse qui a un
moyen de pression vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et pour moi la proposition
de loi et on le voit d'ailleurs dans nos
dans les niches et dans les elle est
vraiment d'abord et avant tout un outil
politique au service d'une cause et
c'est comme ça que j'envisage c'est pour
ça que j'utilise cet outil comme tous
les autres qui sont à ma disposition en
tant que député il y a un dernier point
aussi qui m'a intéressé c'est que vous
voulez pas laisser le monopole de
l'écologie à la gauche vous êtes
d'ailleurs en charge de l'écologie dans
le contre-gouvernement qui a été mis en
place par érectionti chez les
républicains vous avez le sentiment que
c'est un enjeu que la droite a trop
longtemps négligé l'écologie oui et on
n'arrête pas de dire vous savez nous
sommes un parti de gouvernement
gouverner c'est prévoir si on ne prévoit
pas la crise climatique qui arrive
est-ce que en 2027 ou en 2032 on sera
encore un parti de gouvernement et pour
moi l'important c'est que la droite
puisse porter une voix différente de
celle de la gauche et notamment de la
gauche radicale sur la question de
l'écologie pour défendre aussi cette
industrie des carbonée pour défendre
aussi le made in France pour défendre
aussi notre mode de vie qui est en train
de changer de s'adapter aussi au
changement climatique et à la question
des sécheresses du manque d'eau du
risque d'incendie de l'acidification des
océans et on a des choses à porter on
l'apporté par le passé Georges Pompidou
qui crée le premier ministère de
l'Environnement Jacques Chirac et que la
Charte de l'environnement Nicolas
Sarkozy avec le Grenelle l'environnement
et donc c'est à nous de mettre toutes
ses forces historiques et puis des
nouvelles propositions pour incarner
quelque chose en 2027 sur le sujet on va
passer à notre quiz à présent si vous le
voulez bien le principe est assez simple
je vais commencer une phrase et vous
allez devoir la compléter les réseaux
sociaux et moi
favorable pour le contact avec les
habitants pour Twitter un peu plus
sceptique quand les gens me parlent de
mon âge
ça vous énerve ça m'énerve ça m'agace
autant que ça m'agacera quand j'aurai 70
ou 80 ans c'est pas parce que j'ai 30
ans que je dois m'occuper de la jeunesse
c'est pas parce que vous êtes une femme
que vous devez vous occuper de la
diversité ou l'égalité des sexes et donc
quand vous êtes jeune en fait vous devez
porter l'intégralité des sujets et pas
uniquement ceux qui sont liés à votre
âge si j'arrête la politique je me lance
dans la création du ONG vous y avez déjà
pensé c'est déjà pensé c'était déjà dans
mes plans c'est mon engagement
associatif
qui reviendra le jour où j'arrêterai
merci beaucoup Antoine Vermorel d'être
venu dans la politique et moi merci à
vous
[Musique]